where they are going to try to have it
both ways they have arguments prepared
for people that say that you can't have
it both ways the arguments won't make
sense unless you understand their
lexicon they share a vocabulary but they
do not share a dictionary the things
that they say when you say racist they
will have double meanings whether it's a
position of power and privilege or if
it's a whatever Prejudice whatever
whatever fits their attempt at winning
an argument yeah I mean therefore they
win in chaos right when people disagree
they Thrive a lot of times it boils down
to a fundamental philosophy that is
illiberal they are a lot of times you
get consequentialists on the left that
believe that whatever they do is okay if
the consequences are good they are the
and the the most important point is they
are illiberal the the left has moved
Beyond liberalism